what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
Spider-Man news now we do have news
about Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland in
the MCU but we're also still going to be
talking about Andrew Garfield and Toby
McGuire Spider-Man because they could be
coming back not only to the Sony
universe but also possibly back to the
MCU as well which is super exciting plus
not to mention the last time we talked
about Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield
possibly appearing in the MCU Marvel
Studios had not revealed Secret Wars yet
now of course we assumed that everything
was heading to Secret Wars but now it is
official Secret Wars will top off the
Multiverse Saga in 2025 and it looks
like we could be seeing our three
Spider-Man together again and possibly
even in their own movie for Sony so
Spider-Man 4 News Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield news and Secret Wars
news let's start off with Spider-Man 4.
Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios has recently come out and talked
about how he sees Spider-Man and could
have hinted at his future in the MCU
when Kevin feige was asked about his
favorite Peter Parker job he said
teacher and scientists are the ones that
always stick with me because if he
hadn't become Spider-Man that's who he
was anyways that's always the duality of
Spidey between doing what he is now able
to do with these Powers but also trying
to live the life he would have had
anyways or attempting to so Kevin
feige's Favorite Parts about Spider-Man
are of course him being Spidey but also
Peter Parker being a teacher and a
scientist and this could actually be
what we end up seeing Tom Holland's
Peter Parker turn into now we've seen
Spider-Man in high school we've seen
Spider-Man in college we even got a
brief moment of him and the two other
Spider-Man as well being a scientist or
scientist in Spider-Man no way home but
even that was only a brief moment and
we've never seen him be a teacher but
since Kevin feige is so fond of it and
of course he's in charge of the next
Spider-Man film in probably the next
three of them this could be a direction
that we actually see Peter Parker go in
especially if you consider the fact that
now he doesn't really have anyone and
while I do think they will revisit Peter
Parker's relationship with MJ and Ned
and their memories will be restored to
them I do think that we are probably
going to be seeing an older adult
version of Peter Parker in the MCU a
Peter Parker who is not in school in any
type of form not high school not College
not graduate school no type of school at
all but a full adult Peter Parker this
is a direction that Spider-Man has never
really been taken before on film and if
Kevin feige likes Peter being a
scientist and a teacher that could
actually be what we see in Spider-Man 4
5 or 6 or all of them now at the end of
Spider-Man no way home we did see that
Peter Parker was still trying to get his
high school diploma we saw a book called
GED test study manual so he's going to
be out of high school we might see him
in college but Kevin feige might decide
to skip forward a little bit and if we
don't see that happen in Spider-Man 4 I
I'm assuming that we're going to see
that happen in Spider-Man 5 or 6. now I
just want to clarify that this does not
mean that Spider-Man is going to stop
being Spider-Man we obviously would not
have a Spider-Man movie If Peter Parker
was not still going about being
Spider-Man however we haven't really
seen Spider-Man have to handle an adult
job and also being Spider-Man at the
same time that's very different because
you can clearly get fired from a job if
you don't show up but Spider-Man has to
save the world or just fight crime on a
street level and that doesn't really go
on a schedule now of course keep in mind
that Spider-Man no way home its post
credit scene did tease Venom so I am
assuming that regardless of how old
Peter Parker is Venom is still going to
be happening in Spider-Man 4 but this
still could happen if he is an adult and
keep in mind if he is an adult he'll
probably still be a relatively young
adult maybe 30 years old but I for one
do think it would be really really cool
like Kevin feige to see Peter Parker out
of school I think it would be a really
great change now speaking of changes
Spider-Man knowing home changed every
everything when they introduce the other
two Spider-Man in the same universe
interacting with r Peter Parker it was
an iconic moment one of the greatest
moments not only in superhero history
but of course in film history as well
and it looks like the three Spider-Man
may not be done it looks like Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire still could
come back and do another team up film
with Tom Holland Spider-Man now here's
something really important to note the
MCU has kind of contradicted itself with
phase four but that actually ended up
kind of being a good thing as far as
Spider-Man is concerned Loki established
that at the very end of the series
killing he who remains is why
essentially we have a Multiverse and not
just one timeline now and he who remains
basically said that if they kill him
then his other variants are going to
want to dominate the entire Multiverse
they will leave their universe and go
into other universes and start a
multiversal war also incursion will
probably happen that's what Miss minutes
meant when she said that the whole
entire Multiverse was almost destroyed
at the end of the multiversal war
however the villain and Spider-Man no
way home and the other Spider-Man
appeared in that Universe the Earth 616
Universe because apparently of Doctor
Strange's spell then in Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness we were
expecting some mention of Loki and he
remains and essentially the creation of
the Multiverse but that didn't happen in
fact the events of Spider-Man no way
home didn't even affect the events of
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness but here's why it's a good thing
while Dr Strange and nobody else may not
remember who Peter Parker is making it
very unlikely that the other Spider-Man
could find their way back to the same
universe again the huge Multiverse event
in Loki makes it to where of course
everything is going to lead up to Secret
Wars and this is going to be where we
are going to see all of our Spider-Man
back together again now we'll talk about
this more in a bit but there has been
rumors going around recently that Sony
still wants Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield to go in other Spider-Man
projects with Sony now these rumors have
been going around for a long time from
some insiders but there have been new
rumors that they might actually want
Toby Maguire Andrew Garfield to team up
with Tom Holland in another film now
judging by the way that everybody has
been talking about this it really does
seem like this is going to be a separate
film if it does happen then Secret Wars
which would be really really cool but
they obviously would have to find a good
reason for the three Spider-Man coming
together again this is definitely
something that should not be overdone
because then it loses what makes it
special so they can't overdo it but
hopefully Kevin fug is going to be
involved and according to recent reports
Kevin feige is involved with almost
every Spider-Man Sony project so if he's
involved I trust him but of course the
big one is Secret Wars and we've even
heard rumors recently that Andrew
Garfield has possibly signed up for two
movies returning as Spider-Man one of
those being Secret Wars now this is kind
of a no-brainer at this point Secret
Wars is where multiple variants of the
same character get together and fight
together and now Marvel Studios has
confirmed The Last Avengers movie of
phase six is going to be Avengers Secret
Wars also of course The Avengers movie
right before that is Avengers the King
Dynasty which is clearly going to talk
about the Multiverse as well considering
how Kang and all of his other evil
variants are going to try to take over
the Multiverse so this sets up the three
Spider-Man to get together again in a
huge event that definitely would be
meaningful and would not be overdone
then in fact it'll just add to the huge
spectacle that secret Wars is going to
be where we have multiple Captain
Americas fighting together multiple
Spider-Man multiple Iron Man hopefully
multiple Wolverines and other X-Men as
well of course this really is a
no-brainer at this point and if this
doesn't happen I think fans are actually
going to be quite confused we saw them
before in their very own movie why
wouldn't it happen again in this huge
movie where we're seeing it a lot and
definitely by that point in time Peter
Parker should be grown up and he'll also
be teaming up with other grown-up Peter
Parkers but I do hope they throw in a
younger one and I hope that is Miles
Morales especially after they threw in
that Miles Morales Easter egg in
Spiderman no way home where electro said
there's got to be a black Spider-Man out
there somewhere that seemed like a
pretty big setup as well so as you can
see the future of Spider-Man is great it
is very bright right now so let me know
what you hope to see from the future of
Spider-Man in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest Spider-Man news for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof